this is a building in a town on an
island in a territory in the South
Pacific an ocean so vast that barely any
planes transverse it barely any ships
sail through it an area so empty that
when we talk about how many people live
where we look now we do not talk in
magnitudes of billions or even Millions
we talk about the mere thousands of
people who live in this immense precinct
of our world but in a territory on an
island in a town in these buildings live
just 50 of them 50 people on an island
where the only way in or out is on a
boat that comes a few times a year these
people live hundreds of miles away from
the closest other people thousands of
miles away from the closest city and ten
thousand miles or sixteen thousand
kilometers away from their country's
capital in London that's because this is
Pitcairn Island Britain's smallest
farthest and most isolated overseas
territory these 50 people live a life so
removed from those of Belfast errs or
attenborough's or Cardiff IANS or Lennon
errs that believing that they're part of
the same country is just as hard as
believing that Pitcairn itself even
exists that's because to all rational
minds Pitcairn shouldn't exist it just
doesn't make sense for there to be an
island of 50 people living in the UK yet
only absolute extremity of Earth that's
why I sought to make sense of it in the
first season of our new podcast
extremities I explore over six episodes
why and how Pitcairn exists why people
settled there how it became part of the
UK why people still live there how they
get there today how they get food how
they make money how their government
works how they communicate how they plan
to continue existing and much much more
you can find extremeties on all major
podcasting apps at extremities podcast
calm or links are in the description
this is just season 1 and in future
seasons we'll be exploring why and how
other of Earth's most isolated
settlements exist this is something I
and others have been working on for a
while so I do hope you give at least
episode 1 a listen I believe it's
something any Wendover productions
viewer will enjoy so I can't wait to
hear what you think